Well, good morning church.
It is great to see you.
Uh, I love seeing new faces every week.
I love seeing familiar faces every week,
so it's a joy to be back.
If you weren't here last week, I was out, uh, last week.
I was away with our oldest son.
He was involved in a training camp,
and so he was busy on Sunday morning.
And so where we were, I just went ahead
and went to church by myself
and found a Gospel Center church and attended that.
And I'm grateful, first of all,
that the same good news we preach is going forth
there as well.
It's, uh, amazing what God does through all kinds
of different styles and iterations of churches,
but it also gave me a glimpse into something.
I, I haven't had to do this very much in my life, but,
but even I as a pastor
was a bit intimidated walking into a
place I'd never been before.
I don't know anybody, like no
connection, just walking in there.
I felt that as I was walking across the parking lot, felt
that twinge in my stomach a little bit as a pastor.
Like, I'm just going to church with brothers.
Like, but it felt it, right?
And so let me just talk to you if you're new.
Uh, if, if you are new here, we see you.
Like we, we know you're here.
And we know it's not a minor thing
that you would show up somewhere new for the first time.
And so we just wanna say welcome
and thank you for doing that.
Uh, and maybe it doesn't stick right away,
like it takes a moment.
But just keep pressing in, please.
Like, let us help you do that.
We want to try to be as welcoming as we can,
but we know it's a big deal to do that.
And so just help us, help you as best we can.
Uh, but also, if you call Henderson Hills home,
make it a priority to find somebody who's new and,
and pull them into the life of the church with you.
Okay? It's not easy to do, but let's do it as we go.
So I'm grateful for that experience. Help me understand.
But I'm also really grateful
that I get to be a part of this church.
So super thankful to be back and love doing this with you.
Let's now open God's word together.
Turning back to one Samuel.
We'll be in chapter 21, Samuel Chapter 20.
That's where we'll be today.
We've already seen David's been anointed
as the replacement king for Israel.
God chose him while Saul, the one who's being replaced.
He is now openly persecuting David.
He's, he's against God's plan.
He's actually trying to kill David.
He's scared to lose his own position.
And so going after David in all of these ways,
and we'll see it, the rest of the book actually,
David's on the run.
He has to just flee for his life.
Yet, chapter 20 today takes a bit of a deviation
and actually focuses more on Jonathan Saul's son,
how he reacted to his father seeking to kill David's life,
this anointed man, how he, he's seeking to take it away.
And what this is gonna show us,
what it will reveal is the cost of faithfulness,
how painful it can be to choose to be faithful to God.
And, and sometimes that costs us things.
And so follow along with me.
I'm gonna read verses one through 17 to set the context
of the chapter, to dial dialogue
between these brother like friends,
Saul's son, Jonathan and David.
Jonathan and David are dialoguing. Here's how it goes.
Then David fled from Neau in Ramah and came and said,
before Jonathan, what have I done?
What's my guilt? What is my sin
before your father that he seeks my life?
And Jonathan said to him, far from it, you shall not die.
Behold, my father does nothing either great
or small, without disclosing it to me.
And why? Why should my father hide this from me?
It's not so. But David vowed again,
say, no, your father knows.
Well, I found favor in your eyes.
And he thinks, well, don't let Jonathan know
lest he be grieved.
But truly as the Lord lives, as your soul lives, there is
but a step between me and death.
And then Jonathan said to David, okay,
whatever you say I'll do for you.
And so David said to Jonathan, behold,
tomorrow is the new moon.
I should not fail to sit at table to eat a feast
with the king, but let me go
that I may hide myself in the field till the
third day at evening.
And if your father misses me at all, then say, well,
David earnestly asked leave to run to Bethlehem, his city.
There's a yearly sacrifice there for his family.
And if he says, good, it will be well with your servant,
meaning, I'm okay.
But if he's angry, then know that harm is determined by him.
Therefore, Joe, kindly with your servant,
for you've brought your servant into a covenant
of the Lord with you.
But if there is guilt in me, kill me yourself
for why should you bring me to your father?
And Jonathan said, far be it from you.
If I knew that it was determined by my father,
that harm should come to you.
Would I not tell you? And David said, Jonathan, okay,
who will tell me if your father answers you roughly?
And Jonathan said to David, well, I will.
So come, let us go out into the field.
So they both went out into the field
and Jonathan said to David, the Lord, the God of Israel,
be witness when I have sounded out,
meaning I've figured out what he's doing.
My Father about this time tomorrow or the third day.
Behold, if he's well disposed toward David,
shall I not then send and disclose it to you?
But should it please my Father to do you harm the Lord?
Do so to Jonathan.
And more also, if I do not disclose it to you
and send you away that you may go in safety.
May the Lord be with you as he's been with my Father.
If I'm still alive, show me the steadfast love of the Lord
that I may not die
and do not cut off your steadfast love from my house
forever, when the Lord cuts off every one of the enemies
of David from the face of the earth.
And Jonathan made a covenant with the house of David saying,
may the Lord take vengeance on David's enemies.
And Jonathan made David swear again by his love for him,
for he loved him as he loved his own soul.
So first we need to even figure out what's going on here.
Okay? This is a little bit of a circular dialogue
between the two, but what's even going on?
What does the narrator highlight for us to focus on?
Because it seems like Jonathan's unaware
that Saul is intending to kill David.
We as readers already know that David already knows that.
But Jonathan seems like he's a little bit clueless
that Saul had determined to kill David, at least initially.
Jonathan doesn't know. Saul's trying to kill David.
We know that already, multiple times in various ways.
Saul has tried to eliminate David
That this was Saul's direction.
He was so jealous of God's selection of David.
He was so fixated on keeping his power at whatever
cost he needed to.
He was willing to put the young hero David to death
that everybody else saw as a hero.
He was willing to take his life.
And so Jonathan discovers, he's learning
what David has said is going to happen, he believes.
Yet remember, Jonathan also knew this covenant
between David and God.
This anointing from God set David apart.
And so he was already knowing
that David was gonna emerge victorious from the strife
that he was facing, that he would eventually be the king
because he had seen God's anointing on David.
Jonathan was convinced. And
so here in renewing the covenant, that's this whole chapter,
Jonathan committed to protect David.
He said, David, I'm committed to protect you.
I'll tell you if something's going on,
I'll tell you if you need to run all of that,
I'm gonna use my authoritative position as the king's son
to protect the vulnerable to shelter, the one at risk,
to tell David if he needs to run away
or if he needs to do something else.
Jonathan said, I'm, I'm here for you, man.
I'm protecting you. And
so look at David's response.
How did David respond?
He said, well, I'm gonna bless Jonathan.
I promise to bless you as part
of this relational covenant that they had together.
David was going to bless Jonathan.
Look again at verses 14 through 17 to see this.
This is Jonathan saying, if I'm still alive,
show me the steadfast love of the Lord that I may not die.
Do not cut off your steadfast love from my house forever,
when the Lord does cut off every one of the enemies
of David from the face of the earth.
We'll come back to that in a second.
And Jonathan made a covenant with the house of David saying,
may the Lord take vengeance on David's enemies.
And Jonathan made David swear again by his love for him
that he loved him as his own soul.
Now here's why that's so important.
Because what would happen often at this time in history when
a new regime, a new authority would enter in a new dynasty,
began in a nation, the king steps in,
he would kill all the descendants of the previous king
So that none of them could come back
and say, no, no, actually I'm supposed to be the king.
No one can make a claim to the throne.
They would just wipe them out so that their dynasty was
only the one that stood.
And so see what Jonathan did here.
Jonathan asked David to remember Jonathan's house,
to not cut it off.
If that's what David was planning to do.
David's, if it was his plan to cut off the house of Saul,
Jonathan would've been wiped out.
But Jonathan says, Hey, listen, we,
we are brothers together.
Can we, can we not do that?
And instead, can you bless my family?
And notice what David does? He renews the covenant.
We'll actually see later in the ch, in the, the book
that he does fulfill this covenant.
But here he commits to it, says, I'm gonna bless you.
And so they have this dialogue
for 17 verses, what happens next?
Well, Jonathan went to discover his father's intentions.
He says, I'm gonna sound him out. I'm gonna figure it out.
And so David waited, hiding.
I'm gonna summarize the next few verses.
But basically, David didn't go to the feast
that he was supposed to be at.
He would've been expected to be there.
And first day of the feast, Saul just brushed it off like,
oh, well, okay, maybe he's just,
he's unclean or something, okay?
But second day, David's not there.
And so Saul asked Jonathan, where's David?
And Jonathan, as he said to David, he's going
to tell Saul what he said.
Well, David went home to sacrifice with his family.
It was an important feast they needed to sacrifice.
That's where David is.
Well, we're gonna pick it up now in verse 30, watch
how Saul reacted to that one.
Jump down, verse 30.
Then Saul's anger was kindled against Jonathan.
And he said to him, you son of a perverse rebellious woman,
one of the deepest cutting remarks you can ever say towards
someone, do I not know that you've chosen the son of Jesse
to your own shame, to the shame of your mother's nakedness?
For as long as the Son of Jesse lives on the earth,
neither you nor your kingdom shall be established.
Therefore, send and bring him to me for he shall surely die.
And then Jonathan answered, Saul, his father,
why should he be put to death?
What has he done? But Saul hurled his spear at
him to strike him.
So Jonathan knew that his father was
determined to put David to death.
Jonathan Rose from the table in fierce anger, ate no food.
The second day of the month, he was grieved for David
because his father had disgraced him.
And so not only was Saul trying to kill David.
Now here he even tries to kill his own son.
I had somebody earlier today say,
why didn't you just keep the spears away from Saul?
Like he tried to kill David with spears.
And this one, he just picked one up.
Like, just get rid of him.
Like, but here he's trying to even frantically
address every issue by trying to eliminate it.
But I want you to notice something.
It wasn't just that he was trying to kill Jonathan.
Notice he didn't even understand Jonathan.
He failed to understand his sown son.
And here's what I mean by that.
Saul could not figure out
why Jonathan would not want to be the king himself.
'cause remember, that was the typical pathway.
The king, his oldest son, would become the next king.
That was Jonathan. So Saul being the king,
means Jonathan would've been the next king if you
ran the dynasty.
And if he wanted to be the king, since God had replaced
Saul, this, this other dynasty was coming.
We need to eliminate that.
If Jonathan, you're gonna be the king.
Again, Saul could not understand why Jonathan wouldn't want
to walk the same path Saul had walked.
Why wouldn't you wanna be the king?
Why don't you wanna follow the plan that I have
for your life, son?
Well, Jonathan went
and told David the bad news, which of course confirmed that
that means David would have to be on the run the rest
of his life, or at least until Saul died, that he would have
to be separated from, from Jonathan the rest of Saul's life.
But watch again down in verse 42.
This is the very end of the chapter.
Again, a reiteration of this covenant
that would last the rest of their lives, even
as they parted ways, as they ran away from each other.
Watch this verse 42, then Jonathan said to David,
go in peace
because we have sworn both of us in the name
of the Lord saying, the Lord shall be between me and you,
and between my offspring and your offspring forever.
And he rose and departed, and Jonathan went into the city.
Now, we might skip over that phrase, go in peace.
That is all over the Bible as a, an expression
of divine approval.
Go in peace. Go in peace.
Again, David's on the run for his life.
But if you remember last week, like Ryan, so well said,
because Yahweh, the Lord is involved here.
You can have peace even when you're on the
run for your life.
That's what Jonathan says, go in peace.
You Will succeed. You will have victory here.
Go in peace. God is with you. Jonathan believed that.
Now, here's the next question. That's what happened.
But but what does all this mean? That's the story.
But what does this mean?
As we've often seen in one Samuel already,
there's a contrast very clearly here, right?
There's two perspectives on how people responded
to God's anointing of David as the next king.
And it shows us what this means.
Well, first, we've already seen this repeatedly throughout
the book, that Saul clearly opposed God's will.
I mean, Saul was completely against Yahweh's will
in every way, in every step,
which led to his removal, right?
He had lack of faith in God.
So he, he was removed from the kingship,
but he's still in the position.
And his opposition to God's will showed up like this.
He could have humbled himself.
He could have submitted to the plan of God through David.
He could have gotten outta the way
and said, okay, David's the king.
Now I'm out. I abdicate my throne. David's the king.
This is who God said is gonna be it.
He could have done that, and he would've saved himself
and saved his people a whole lot
of pain, But he never did.
In fact, the rest of the book is the story
of Saul trying to remove David from the equation.
That's his whole focus.
Instead of being the king leading his people towards Yahweh,
he was just trying to eliminate David.
He never submitted to God's plan, never submitted to
God's will because it went against his selfish heart.
That's Saul. But Jonathan,
Jonathan on the other hand, he,
he is faithfully seeking Yahweh's.
Will Saul clearly opposed Yahweh's, will
Jonathan faithfully sought God's will.
He was even following God by supporting
and following David above
and beyond his own father
who wasn't seeking God's will.
He said, I'm following God's plan here.
Now, here's the interesting thing.
This is where the tension comes.
He never abandons his father.
He even goes back to his father
and dies with his father in battle.
Yet his
heart was with David, right?
His heart was with David.
He needed to honor his father,
but he had to follow God by honoring
and have his heart towards David.
Why was his heart that way?
Because he knew David was God's anointed.
He knew that was God's plan again, even though he knew
that meant he was never gonna be the king himself.
He was supposed to be next in line,
but he says, I don't care.
That doesn't matter to me.
That doesn't matter because I'm abandoning personal, uh,
a pursuit of personal greatness.
I'm abandoning that completely
because my commitment to God must have priority.
I don't need to follow my own pathway
or my father's pathway.
I'm following God's pathway.
And so in that, even his abandonment
of personal greatness in
that we actually see Jonathan's greatness, right?
Because his, his willingness to count it all as loss
for the sake of obedience to Yahweh, he abandoned
because he knew that was priority
over anything else in his life.
What a contrast, Saul, Jonathan, how each responded
to the Lord here, this is what it means.
But a good teacher always asks a further question when it
comes to what it seems like.
All right? That's the end. A good teacher asks a further
question, typically a question, something like, okay, why?
Why does this matter? Right? That's, that's the question.
Now, here's what it means. Okay?
We, we can see the contrast.
We can see Saul and Jonathan's responses.
But, but why is this here? Why does it matter?
Well, I wanna share just three lessons from this
that I feel like we can apply
to our lives showing us why this matters.
Why does this picture get painted the way it is?
Why does it speak to us and what does it do for us today?
Well, here's part of what chapter 20 teaches us.
First, it's that friendships can be life-giving and deep
and friendships can be
deep life-giving nourishing in our lives.
We saw this a couple weeks ago when David
and Jonathan committed, uh, to each other.
There, there was this sense of, of Jonathan committing
to David as the new king.
There was a com, a covenant there.
But here it's fully formed.
It's fully showing up in chapter 20 where they're willing
to protect one another in risky ways.
David's promising to bless Jonathan's descendants.
There was tearful goodbyes.
There's love beyond anything that's just surface level.
There's a soul level kind of love here.
Again, don't think too, too much of this.
The text doesn't let us, but what does that mean for us?
Why is this here the way it is?
Well, I know that many of us have been hurt
by friendships over the years,
Like Deep pain from friends
who turned on you.
But here's the truth. Our experience does not mean
that friendships like this are actually impossible,
because where did their commitment come from?
Where did that deep soul level love come from?
Well, first, it was because of their shared faith in Yahweh
That Their hearts, both of them were primarily
oriented toward the Lord.
Like that was focus number one, our hearts towards God.
Along with that, there was also a shared mission,
a shared pursuit of the most important things.
They were both focused on what God wanted them to do, not
what they wanted to do or their selfish desires wanted.
It was what does God want? And that's what I want.
Do you have friends like this, right?
Like buzzing woody maybe. Like you kind of see that, right?
You got a friend. I don't know if
that's like, but you see what I mean?
Like there's, there's a depth to theirs
that is way different.
Serious, though, a lot of us have a whole lot
of acquaintances, but very few, if any,
friendships where we walk away, filled up,
where we walk away sacrificed for,
and we sacrifice for them.
And there's a deep, deep, deep love
where they know everything about you
and they still yell, love you.
The same. Do we have those?
I fear that most of us don't.
And so if you're sitting there and
you think, okay, well that's me.
I, I feel alone right now. I don't have
those kind of people in my life.
What do I do? You feel alone? I don't have that.
Okay, what do I do? Well, you have to take a risk.
You have to step out.
You, you have to take a risk, step out.
You have to realize that love is costly,
love is risky, and you might get hurt again.
But if you never step out in faith,
you will never reap the rewards
of what's on the other side of that step.
And so take that step. Open up your life.
Trust the Lord as you seek this, right?
You're not trusting that person.
Ultimately, you're trusting the Lord
through his means to encourage you.
And let me just say, as a side note,
I've had too many conversations with people who tried that.
And they got just ghosted. They people left.
They didn't respond and bailed on him.
Sat with a young man just this week who tried to reach out
'cause we'd connected him with someone tried to reach out
and the guy just never responded.
And he was so discouraged by that.
Listen, if somebody reaches out to you
and somebody says, I need help.
I need a friend. Don't bail.
Like spend some time sacrifice.
Make it a point to engage them, to care for them,
to befriend them, grow deep with them, give life back
and forth to one another.
We don't wanna hurt anyone. It happens too often.
But Jonathan and David show us that that kind
of friendship is actually possible.
But here's something else. Chapter 20 teaches us,
it's that family can be hard and soul straining.
Family can be hard and soul straining.
That was Jonathan and Saul's relationship, right?
When a family has an imbalanced spiritual dynamic
that pulls at its very fabric,
and some of you know what I'm talking about, right?
Some of you have parents who are not believers
and you felt this tension that as you follow Jesus
and you're seeking to obey him,
they might completely disagree with everything you're doing.
Some of you have children who are pursuing a lifestyle
against everything you've taught,
against everything you've modeled for them their whole life.
And it makes family gatherings really difficult.
It's similar with Jonathan and Saul, right?
They were at opposite ends in their, their faith,
their devotion to Yahweh.
Jonathan seeking to obey God,
I'm doing everything I can to follow God.
Saul just acting religious at times when it made it
convenient, opposite ends of the spectrum
to such an extent that Saul could not even see
that Jonathan was trying to honor the Lord
by following David, even trying
to kill his own son For his faith.
My wife and I have been in ministry long enough now
that we have seen variations of families,
this dysfunctional, many of our college students, many
of our young couples as we're walking
through premarital stuff with them in our years of ministry,
we've seen this over and over
and over, where these people we're sitting with in church,
in, in times together premarital,
and we're talking with them that
they are closer to each other.
They're closer to their peers and and brothers
and sisters in Christ in the church.
They're closer to them than they are
to their biological families.
Now, that's something the only Holy Spirit can do
because they didn't know each other
before they showed up in Weatherford, right?
And it's all of a sudden now God's knit them together.
But think of the tension that puts right.
A young couple trying to follow Jesus in their marriage
and both their families are pulling 'em apart part.
But here's what that means. It makes it essential
that the church is a place for those kind of people to land.
That they feel like their their safe.
Because if their pursuit of Jesus puts them at odds
with their biological family, they better know
that they have a family here no matter what.
In fact, it was one of those college students in Weatherford
who pointed the following verse out in Psalm 68.
I don't know if I'd ever seen this in this way before,
but it speaks to this situation.
Psalm 68, verses five and six says, father of the fatherless
and protector of widows is God in his holy habitation.
God settles the solitary in a home.
Oh, and we'd think of orphans and wi. Okay, great.
But what about somebody like Jonathan who's been kind
of run off from his family and you're pursuing Jesus
and your family says, I don't care about that
and you can't come home, or whatever it is.
Do they have a home? Okay, so how do we apply this?
Lemme talk to you parents first, including myself.
Don't get in the way of your kids following the Lord.
Like if they wanna move overseas
to share the gospel, celebrate that.
Don't try to say No, you can take my grand babies away.
Don't ever like you celebrate that.
'cause They feel God's call in their life
to go share the gospel and sacrifice
and cost for everything.
Like if they don't wanna go to college,
if they don't wanna get the same degree that you got
and follow through and take the family business,
whatever it is, instead they wanna go to seminary,
serve the Lord vocationally with their career.
You say yes to that
And on and on and on.
We can go, right? We can say,
stop getting in the way of them.
And you're, you're completely not following Jesus
and they're wanting to, and you're saying, no,
I'm too tired to go.
No, you. You get 'em to church, right?
You do these kind of things
to foster their hunger for the Lord.
Lemme talk to you. Kids, children, students, whatever.
Don't antagonize your parents.
Don't push their buttons on purpose just
because you feel more spiritual than they are.
Right? That doesn't work. Either.
You respect, you honor as best you can,
but you prioritize Jesus over everything else.
Here's the key, right? All of us, every single, no matter
what age, pursue the Lord wholeheartedly, right?
That's the way it's gonna work out.
And we're just fostering this in feeding
us amongst each other.
Family can be hard, can be soul straining,
but it can also be life-giving.
It can be encouraging.
It can be discipling your own children
and watching God do something with that.
But here's what it all sets up.
The last point today, really why this
chapter actually matters the most.
Jonathan's life shows us that faith will be costly,
yet it will be ever rewarding.
Faith will be costly.
We don't like talking about this very much
'cause it kind of pushes against our comfort.
Faith will cost you, but it will be ever rewarding.
Jonathan knew he was not supposed to abandon his father,
but he also knew that his commitment
to his father could never claim
priority over his commitment to Yahweh.
And that cost him something, didn't it?
That cost him the future kingship.
It almost cost him his life getting
pinned to the wall with a spear.
It eventually does cost him his life in battle.
But how do you think God saw Jonathan's actions?
He was pleased with Jonathan's faith.
He was pleased with Jonathan's obedience,
his commitment to God's plan.
He was pleased with Jonathan.
Listen, it's no different for us today.
Again, we don't like talking about this,
but God sent his son in such a way
that it would divide people.
It would divide even households.
I mean, Jesus said it. Listen to Matthew chapter 10.
This is verses 37 through 39.
Jesus says, whoever loves father
or mother more than me is not worthy of me.
Whoever loves son
or daughter more than me is not worthy of me.
And whoever does not take his cross
and follow me is not worthy of me.
Whoever finds his life here will lose it.
And whoever loses his life here for my sake will find it.
Does that not sound so radical to our modern ears?
Like that sounds completely outta whack?
Like Jesus could never have said that? No.
'cause family is most important to us.
We revolve our whole lives around our kids,
and we say, this is the most of, we're gonna get everything
for them and make it right for them.
Jesus, what did he say?
He said that your kids cannot become an idol.
Your kids cannot become preeminent.
A good thing cannot become a God thing in your life.
There are so many distractions that compete for our focus.
They compete for our attention.
They compete for our devotion, for our time, for our energy.
But coming to Jesus means dying to self.
And even though that death to self means you have
to set aside what you want,
E even though submitting to him
and his will like for Jonathan was costly,
and it is costly, it will be costly for you.
Setting aside all those desires saying, I don't want that.
I want you. You set up, it's costly.
Yes, but it is absolutely worth it.
How? Because you're not the first.
Jesus himself took up his cross
to pay your price, to make you worthy before God.
But that's not even all of it. Like, yes, he died.
He, he said, you pick up your cross. But he did it first.
He took up his cross to make you worthy.
But that's not even all because he didn't stay dead.
Remember, right? That's not the end of the story.
He now freely gives life to those who do die
to themselves for his sake.
So you die, okay? But you know what? You get life.
He says, I give you life that you're dead.
I'm dead in my trespasses and sins,
but in him, I am made alive spiritually and forever.
And that happens because we've seen him.
We've seen him as better than anything else.
We say, God, I want to obey your will. God.
I want to crucify my desires.
He says, okay, here's life and life abundant.
So is it costly to follow Jesus? Absolutely.
It's, but
Romans eight says that the sufferings
of this present time are not worth comparing with the glory
that is to be revealed to us.
It is costly. You suffer.
It's not even close, not worth comparing to the glory
that is to be revealed to us.
And until that time comes, listen, I am sure it continues.
That neither death nor life, nor angels nor rulers,
nor things present, nor things to come, nor powers,
nor height, nor depth, nor anything else in all creation,
will be able to separate us from the love
of God in Christ Jesus, our Lord.
The cost is high, But did you see it?
The rewards are infinitely higher.
How do you know the love of God? You say, I'm out.
Jesus, I need you. And nothing
separates you from that love.
Whatever cost, whatever sacrifice, whatever suffering.
It's not worth comparing to the glory,
but it's also never going
to separate you from the love of God.
Jonathan understood the love of God
for the first time in his life, and he said, I'm in.
And God said, I, yeah, let's go. Same for you.
The cost is high, but the rewards are ever higher.
So trust him. Trust him.